tiempo atrás fue el país más grande de
áfrica sudán tiene una población de 43
millones de personas en su mayoría
musulmanas con el árabe como lengua
oficial y fronteras que se extienden
hasta el mar rojo un país desgarrado por
las guerras civiles
primero entre las regiones del norte y
del sur dos guerras de 17 22 años y
millones de muertos en 2005 se firmó un
acuerdo de paz seis años después
sudán del sur proclama su independencia
en el occidente otra guerra sacude a
sudan en 2003 en la región de darfur un
conflicto entre las fuerzas sudanesas y
los rebeldes de las minorías étnicas que
acabó con la vida de 300.000 personas y
desplazó internamente a 25 millones
durante 30 años sudan fue gobernado con
puño y hierro por omar al bashir hasta
ser destituido por el ejército en 2019
después de cuatro meses de masivas
protestas populares el ex dictador es
acusado de genocidio y crímenes de lesa
humanidad debido a las violaciones de
derechos humanos y supuestos vínculos
con el terrorismo sudan está bajo el
embargo de eeuu nunca ha podido
desarrollar y es uno de los países más
empobrecidos del mundo la escasez de gas
electricidad y combustible es algo
cotidiano para los sudaneses la secesión
del sur en 2011 también privó de casi
todas las reservas de petróleo en el
ámbito cultural la nación africana
cuenta con muchos tesoros arqueológicos
inexplorados pirámides en particular más
numerosas que en egipto riquezas aún
desconocidas